[Music]
Disney movies are a part of most
children's lives the catchy songs
beautiful animations and fun storylines
make these film some of the most
entertaining movies of all times
although Disney movies are made for kids
animators and script writers have
included some pretty inappropriate adult
jokes into many of the films if this is
your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we're sharing 10 adult jokes
hidden inside Disney movies cars in the
movie Cars Lightning McQueen approaches
two of his biggest female fans as the
female cars drive up to him they flash
their headlights it's pretty much the
equivalent to a groupie flashing her
boobs to her favorite celebrity the joke
was very subtle and it definitely flew
over many children's heads but adults
caught on to it right away when the film
was released back in 2006 Toy Story 3
when Ken and Barbie meet up in Toy Story
freezer chemistry together is
electrifying Ken innocently flirts with
Barbie but Barbie kicks things up a
notch by telling Ken he has a nice ass
just get it it's not the raunchy adult
Josephine has used in one of his movies
but the play on words was definitely
hilarious
101 Dalmatians Disney's live-action
remake of 101 Dalmatians slipped in a
subtle innuendo that had many parents
raising their eyebrows in the movie
Roger and Anita reveal they're expecting
a baby as well as a litter of puppies
karela deville looked at Roger and says
well you've been a busy boy haven't you
even though it's obvious the puppies
belong to the Dalmatians Pongo and
Perdita if you didn't miss the
opportunity to clip in another
disturbing and inappropriate joke
accusing roger of cheating on his wife
with a dog Cars 2
you remember this team from cards -
right the villains in the film are
called the lemons and they're the old
and junky cars Clint no.11
they're jealous of all the new and shiny
cars so they go to great lengths to
bring them down when they think they've
just needed in their quest to room the
new cars lives they decide to throw a
lemon party and celebrate Disney was
really brave to allow this joke that
slipped through the cracks because it's
been referenced to some very
inappropriate content from an adult web
site
I mean in Bambi the character flower
experiences his first kiss
after the flute his body tenses up he
becomes fifth blood swells inside his
body and he falls over backward the
children the scene appears to be
innocent but to adults they were quick
to realize the flower with one of the
first in two characters to get a little
too excited on the jump if you catch
your drift
wreckit-ralph brows made numerous sexual
innuendos in the film record rao was the
one that stands out the most is when he
finds out pac-man is invited to his
games 30th anniversary party Rob screams
pac-man they invited pac-man that cherry
chasin got muncher isn't even on this
game the term is cherry chaser is used
to describe someone who likes to take
girls virginity's and as for the term
god muncher is another inappropriate
term that relates to sex acts Aladdin
and the king of seas in the 1996 gem
Aladdin in the King of Thieves
many parents became outraged when they
heard this joke in the scene where
aladdin and Jasmine are getting married
an earthquake occurs the genie says
under his breath I thought the earth
wasn't supposed to move until after the
honeymoon
- a kid's joke is harmless and funny
which results the genies reference to
aladdin and Jasmine consummating their
marriage took things a little too far
frozen in frozen Kristoff begins asking
and it question is me how much he really
knows about him when he asked her about
his foot size and a taste which size
doesn't matter
this was Anna's way of relating Kristoff
to size to the size of his manhood
and according to Anna the size of his
package isn't an issue for her this is a
pretty risky joke by his new standards
don't you agree
the Emperor's New Groove this is
definitely one of the most inappropriate
scenes in a Disney film Kronk is
sleeping outside with a hint directly
covering his manhood in the movie The
Emperor's New Groove
this was Disney's way of subtly
preferring to Franck itching attention
it please if you don't understand this
joke to face a way to describe when a
guy gets too excited well these
underneath the covers so Little Mermaid
when earth Bella transforms into Vanessa
and she's text to marry the prince
mermaid notice the minister who was
officiating a ceremony
appears to be excited his pants have a
bulge that can be clearly seen
and although Disney has denied that the
graphic animation was done on purpose
many parents found this hard to believe
were you shocked by any of these adult
jokes hidden within Disney films react
in the comments section down below and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
[Music]
you
[Music]